als er wieder zurück corona crafter
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal meine lieben
freunde des bereits im titel und schauen
uns heute gemeinsamen lustige google
bewertungen an und wir starten direkt
mit dieser bewertung die eine person zu
dem alexanderplatz geschrieben hat und
zwar alexander ist kein schöner name ja
würde ich auch deswegen dann einen stern
von 5 geben kann hat meine halbe leben
mit raus die nächste bewertung wurde
zudem google eintrag zum berliner tor
gepostet und zwar ist das berliner tor
eine u bahn station in hamburg und das
hier wurde darunter geschrieben und zwar
drecksloch da hat mich meine ex
verlassen
irgendwie hat bisher keine bewertung was
mit dem eigentlichen ort zu tun
allerdings hat die nächste bewertung
wirklich was mit dem mord zu tun und
zwar mit dem brandenburger tor und es
war schreibt doch der liebe wie ordnet
an do lecce sehr kalt auf beiden seiten
des tores da sich die türen nicht
schließen lassen und es zieht wie
hechtsuppe
da wäre wer kennt es nicht wenn beim
brandenburger tor die türen nicht
geschlossen werden und ist dann wie
hechtsuppe zieht mich mein ganzes leben
zieht wie hechtsuppe gerade an mir
vorbei das hier ist eine weitere
bewertung zum brandenburger tor
zwar schreibt der thomas tolles gebäude
kaum zu glauben dass es von brandenburg
nach berlin gebracht wurde
es tut mir leid dass ich hier wieder nur
klatsch aber was anderes fällt mir bei
der bewertung liegt ihnen aber ich habe
noch eine dritte bewertung zum
brandenburger tor für euch und zwar von
den lieben user harald kranke und zwar
schreibt er da steht ja gar nicht in
brandenburg beschiss und brandenburger
kann man da auch nicht kaufen ja die
würde ich an zeigen die haare als
nächsten zwei bewertungen haben wir
ebenfalls etwas mit einer berliner
sehenswürdigkeit zu tun und zwar mit dem
bundestag
und zwar schreibt dort die userin mira
sehr enttäuscht will ein parlament das
nur genau das macht was ich für richtig
halte aber im bundestag wird andauernd
debattiert und dann handeln die
irgendwelche kompromisse aus und der
liebe user mit dem namen yasin celik
schreibt schlechter service musste erst
mal durchs fenster klettern um
reinzukommen als ich dann drin war wurde
ich von den sicherheitsleuten zu boden
gestoßen weil boehner habe ich auch
nicht bekommen menschenrechte sind
ziemlich abstoßen die erste bewertung
hat eine person unter den google eintrag
von china geschrieben und zwar hat die
person vier sterne gegeben und
geschrieben überfüllt mit chinesen
also wenn ich in köln bin fragt sie mich
auch voll ab dass hier nur kölner sind
nächste google rezension wurde unter dem
beitrag des eiffelturms gepostet und
zwar hat tommy der wilhelm geschrieben
da war ich noch nie ich war noch niemals
in paris la la la la la la la la ok
tommy der wilhelm angeführt eine
bewertung und wo wir uns gerade schon
eine bewertung zum land china angeschaut
haben zeige ich euch jetzt eine
bewertung zum kontinent europa von louis
merkel und zwar schreibt er pretty nice
kontinent easily max uthoff händel des
defenders of seven kontinents list
nächsten bewertungen wurde unter den
google eintrag vom fernsehturm berlin
gepostet und zwar hat die liebe katja
geschrieben unbezahlbare ausblick über
berlin waren leider nicht oben aber sie
doch von unten schon spannend aus alles
klar
wahrscheinlich kannst du den ausblick
beschreiben wenn du es nur von unten
angeschaut hat und die nächste person
hat urlaub in new york gemacht und hat
unter denen google eintrag von der
freiheitsstatue die bewertung
geschrieben no leberkäs ja also das
sollten die amerikaner echte ändern da
hinten minuten allerdings seiner
bewertungen eines ortes in köln und zwar
der u-bahn-station friesenplatz und zwar
schreibt darin eine person hässliche u
bahn
dennoch bin ich gern hier ja man ist ja
gern hässlich
[Musik]
ich denke die ganze zeit ich wusste blut
aber dann musst du durch spucke kann man
sich grabsteine online bestellen unter
dem google eintrag vom stuttgarter
amtsgericht wurde gepostet 150 euro
strafe nur weil ich den termin vergessen
habe
du kannst nicht mal das wort strafe
richtig schreiben also ich glaube du
hast auch etwas anderes als nach den
nächsten beiden rezensionen wurden unter
den eintrag eines gymnasiums geschrieben
und zwar schreibt dort einen gewissen
steam welt iks dankt ihm welt ist die
schule erträglich und litt also es ist
wohl irgend so eine schülergruppe oder
so und darunter schreibt allerdings nur
zwei sterne und sagt leider wird die
schule von einer gruppe böser jungs
regiert die sich team welt nennen man
ist nirgends sicher vor denen so schnell
können meinungen auseinander gehen die
nächste person war zu besuch in los
angeles und hat sich das hollywood
zeichen angeschaut und hat sich dann
gedacht hey ich schreib doch mal unter
dem google alltag von hollywood zeichen
wäre besser in comics amt
du wärst besser wenn du die schnauze
warum sind sie hier die nächste
rezensionen wurde unter den google
eintrag von der jugendvollzugsanstalt
achim gepostet und zwar mir hat es
gefallen nette wörter und zellengenossen
waren die besten drei jahre meines
lebens
ja ja ja da hast du wohl nicht so ein
geheimes leben glaube ich haben wir nur
wieder zu zwei bewertungen zu einem
kölner ort und zwar dem kölner dom und
zwar schreibt der user franz sie cool
eine bewertung mit einem stern und zwar
kirche
ja
bewertungen sind dazu da und anderen
leuten zu helfen was sie da erwartet
also dankeschön dafür und der markus
mühle schreibt auch eine bewertung zum
kölner dom und zwar unfreundliche
mitarbeiter plus jesus waren nicht da ja
blöd den erwischt man leider nicht jeden
tag sondern nur dienstags und
donnerstags wenn wir nun allerdings zu
einer bewertung die unter den google
eintrag von der kings cross station in
london gepostet wurde und zwar schreibt
der user klo domo um wie viel uhr fährt
der hogwarts express auf gleis 9 34 thh
du ganz lustig aber jetzt bewertungen
wurde unter dem eintrag von einem
gewissen maß an restaurant aus derby
geschrieben und zwar schreibt der user
doug freedman food for thought i'd guess
what they get up sleeping mit my way i
can't give it morden street stars
because of dead werk endlich fest ist
eigentlich okay gewesen und ich gebe dem
ganzen aber nur drei sterne weil dann
der markt bald mit meiner frau
geschlafen adresse person von der wir
uns jetzt gleich sofort die rezension
anschauen werden hat urlaub am pazifik
gemacht hat sich dann gedacht hey ich
geb den pazifik nur einen stern auf
google weil ist mir zu blau
ich frag mich wirklich einfach nur noch
ob das deren ernst ist oder ob die
einfach trollen wollen und das hier ist
der google ein tag von einer pizzeria
und der liebe helmut gibt der pizzeria
nur einen stern und schreibt schlechter
umgang mit dem kunden und der inhaber
der pizzeria antwortet sogar und
schreibt du lügner man werde behindert
bist kommt vorbei und seien auch bei der
gesicht wenn du nicht genug damit
aber wie oft habe ich im heutigen video
jetzt eigentlich schon geklatscht die
nächsten beiden rezension und wurden
unter den google eintrag von der polizei
hauptstelle frankfurt gepostet und zwar
schreibt naja filmen sie mir nicht ins
gesicht und eine handel person die hier
zensiert ist schreibt great place to
hang out
er kennt es nicht wenn man langeweile
hat einfach mal einer polizeistation ein
bisschen abhängen wer nun allerdings
wieder zu einer berliner
sehenswürdigkeit und zwar im reichstag
meine lieben freunde und zwar schreibt
ein user als rezension drunter geht
pizza
das ist ja auch deren hauptaufgabe da
einfach super pizza herzustellen und
unter den google eintrag der stadt
münchen hat der liebe user l kelch
geschrieben es gibt bessere leben ja
bessere leben als münchen die nächste
person hat urlaub in tokio gemacht und
hat danach auf google geschrieben voll
mit japanern nicht schön zu genießen
ja es halt blöd wenn man nach japan
fliegt und dann sind ja überall japaner
und der liebe tyler hat unter den google
eintrag vom weißen haus geschrieben it
was great and first but as tun ist ein
hotte fans ein ende jetzt amberger pixel
was attacked bei docs entscheidende lag
bei apple zur overall very nice looking
at every little bit more polleit im plus
ja unfassbar da will man einfach mal
einen sound klettern vom weißen haus
sieht man auch einmal angeschlossen das
ist die vorletzte bewertung die wir uns
anschauen uns verschreibt eine person
unter das wiener landesgericht diese
bauern haben wir drei jahre haft für
körperverletzungen gedrückt ich habe ihn
nur leicht in den bauch geschmeckt
schlechtestes gericht
ich solle einfach aufhört zu klatschen
wir kommen allerdings nun schon zum
letzten google bewertungs viel mehr oder
weniger für die heutige episode und zwar
schreibt heller wahnsinn
unter den google eintrag von der
zugspitze gestern netten ausflug mit dem
kindergarten zum gipfel unternommen oben
keinerlei restaurants oder ähnliches ist
negativ anzumerken wir haben dann auf
dem etwas windigen gibson gepicknickt
nächste woche planen wir ein wenig mehr
zeit für die rollifahrer ein und folgt
mit der seniorengruppe aus dem
altersheim geil dass du mit denen dann
auf jeden fall den berg dann da wird
sprachen lernen an der stelle durch das
heutige video allerdings auch beenden
beide lieben freunde es tut mir
unfassbar leid dass ich hier komplett
sitze wie eine leiche und hier mit
klopapier mir die ganze zeit die nasen
putz während des videos und die hier
hals schmerzt uns reinhauen allgemein
mit lyons wertes opfer gerade bin
allerdings geht es mir gerade
gesundheitlich wirklich nicht so gut ich
weiß nicht genau was das ist ich war
schon beim arzt ich habe definitiv nicht
den chor oder virus
ist aber auch egal ich wollte mich
einfach nur noch meine verfassung hier
gerade in diesem video noch in dem
letzten winter auch in den nächsten
videos wahrscheinlich noch entschuldigen
wenn euch das video hier allerdings
heute trotzdem gefallen dann würde ich
mich sehr darüber einen daumen hoch von
euch freundschaften 40.000 der hammer
weil ein leih gleich drei gesundheit für
mich und wo ich gerade schon dabei bin
ein bisschen mehr zu quatschen im auto
ihr könnt noch für uns abstimmen für
sander und mich beim deutschen podcast
preis einen link dazu findet ihr unten
in der infobox heute ist der letzte tag
wo ihr habt stimmen können das wird uns
auf jeden fall sehr freunde bekommen da
nichts für aber es wäre schon lustig
wenn sandy und ich auf der tribüne
dastehen würden
völlig gaga laudatio halten würden aber
egal ich glaube ich jetzt kotzen
[Musik]